thank you to have rishi soon at with us
uh the chancellor in the on the program
this morning hello to you
first time we've met in person nice to
see you thank you for coming in we
appreciate it
um lots to talk about do you want to
talk about overseas aid though it's
dominating the newspapers today the
archbishop of canterbury has called it
shameful
and wrong that you're cutting it to 0.5
and it would lead
according to one of your colleagues to a
hundred thousand
preventable deaths how does that sit
with your religious
beliefs well i think this is about
trying to focus
on the priorities that the british
people have at a time of enormous
difficulty for our economy and public
finances i set some of that out
yesterday
uh which your viewers will be aware
about we're facing an economic crisis
the likes which we we haven't seen and
in that context
i wanted to get on with delivering on
the priorities that people have and
whether that's better public services
new hospitals better schools safer
streets also
delivering an infrastructure investment
that we haven't seen in in decades to
really transform
this country and in order to do all of
that i had to make some difficult
choices of which aid was one of them and
what we've said is
given the situation we won't meet the
0.7
target we hope to return to it when the
fiscal situation allows but we'll still
be spending 10 billion pounds on aid
next year
and if you look at as a percentage of
gdp that's 0.5 percent which will still
make us
more generous than almost any other
major economy
so more than most of our peers and we'll
still be one of the
uh most active countries lead globally
with the leadership that will show
whether it's peacekeeping bringing
vaccines to the developing world
we're doing so much and people should
hold their head up high about the role
we're playing
you have broken a promise to the poorest
children in the world
how does that sit with you as a father
well actually
if you look at what we're doing to help
some of the poorest children in the
world
you take something called gavi which is
the multilateral organization which
provides
vaccinations and immunizations against
infectious diseases
that's 75 million children we are the
largest owner
internationally to that effort i said we
we do
more than our fair share we set an
example to other countries around the
world if you look at whether
it's our european peers or canada or the
us as a percentage of gdp we'll be
spending
more than all of them next year we also
express
our leadership and our values through
other things we do
we obviously had a very significant
defense settlement recently the largest
increase in defense spending in 30 years
and that helps us do humanitarian work
around the world
particularly peacekeeping so when i look
at it across the board
again i feel very good about the role
that we're playing to tackle the world's
most difficult problems
this is one part of it and it's right
given the context to make sure we
prioritize that's what we've done
you have to change the law in order to
cut money to those that are most
deserving
around the world um what message does
that send to other world leaders
well actually the existing law that we
have does have a
set of provisions in it which allow for
temporary
uh difference from the aid target given
the circumstances you're changing the
law
yeah well that'd be for more than one
year well it's just because the economic
outlook
is so uncertain i'm sure you've covered
that elsewhere in the program we're
dealing with
such economic uncertainty in order to
make sure that we don't properly
the foreign secretary making a statement
today later on about
the approach to legislation and we'll
set that out then
but you're completely comfortable in
your own skin well of course
is it a difficult decision of course
it's a difficult decision you know no
one
no one wants to be having to make these
difficult decisions but this is
this is about an economic emergency that
i described yesterday we're going to
have
record level peacetime record levels of
borrowing and debt
the economy is in in in a very very
difficult time well i think that's the
part i think is wrong i don't think
anyone could characterize
our level of support for the poorest
countries is turning our back
will be spending more as a percentage of
gdp than france and canada the us japan
italy we spend what we do as a nation
what it means to us in the world
standing that we are saying that
actually you know what
we're not going to spend that money what
what does that mean a hundred thousand
what do what does that say okay if
that's the case
all these other countries that spend far
less than we do would if you had them
here
would you would you say to them well
what would you say are you
you do look at yourself in the number
but i think and i think
because of what i've done a hundred
thousand people could well equally you
could get any pretty much any other
leader in here from any other country
and say
well you guys are making a choice not to
do what we're doing here
and i'm very proud and i and i stand
here
very proud of this country's
contribution to tackling the world's
most difficult problems
helping the world's poorest and making a
difference on the issues like climate
change and there's
lots of things that we do as a country
people should feel
enormously proud uh just let's take
coronavirus that is the
most pressing pressing issue at the
moment that there is a
body called covax which is trying to
assemble vaccines
for the poorest countries obviously
that's probably the most significant
thing we could do at the moment
you know what we're the largest donor to
that body it's called the advanced
advanced multilateral commitments market
commitments that gets vaccines into
these countries
we are the country that is doing most so
all your viewers watching should feel
very good about the role that we're
selling
they might say it shouldn't be either or
public sector pay freeze um
1.3 million key workers um police
officers firefighters
and the like um you are a very wealthy
man what does it
say to those workers who are struggling
when you say you know
you're gonna have to have a pay freeze
this year well we've talked about the
economic and fiscal context already so
given that context i i also then had a
look at what's happening between the
public and private sectors and what we
knew coming into this crisis there's
already a disparity with public sector
wages generally
higher than private sector wages and
then that difference
disagrees that difference well that's
what the official statistics say
once you take weight in uh experience
and age with the greatest respect the
latest figures from the office of
national statistics that we have for
2019
show that even when you take into
account characteristics and pensions
there was at least a seven percent pay
premium for public sector
that pay premium has certainly widened
in the last six months because what
we've seen over the last six months is
private sector wages have fallen
by a percent public sector wages have
risen by around four percent
on top of that people in the private
sector are losing their jobs their hours
are being cut they're being furloughed
none of that is happening in the public
sector so given the context
i i couldn't justify an across-the-board
universal pay increase for the public
sector so what we've done instead is
taken a targeted approach
so that means the nhs subject to the
recommendations of the pay review bodies
will get a pay rise next year so nurses
people working in
hospitals for everyone else we've paused
pay rises
next year but we want to make sure that
we protect those on lower incomes so if
you're in the public sector and you earn
less than 24
000 pounds which is the uk median salary
so in
half your viewers probably earn less
than that that's the median then you
will get at least a 250 pounds
pay increase so making sure that we
protect that's over two million people
in the public sector who will benefit
from that
if you take all of that together what
does it mean a majority
of people who work in the public sector
next year will see their pay
increase and i think that is a
reasonable and fair approach given the
circumstances i know you don't want to
go into figures
in too much detail as far as how we're
going to pay off our covered debt but
tax rises are inevitable at some stage
aren't they well
you know yesterday was a spending review
we were setting the budget
and i was very clear when i set out the
fiscal situation
that what what's happening this year is
obviously not sustainable you know that
your viewers know that it's right to act
in the way that we have this year
to protect the economy in the medium
term and i'm glad that the
office for budget responsibility who are
our independent fiscal watchdog
acknowledged that what we've done
has made a difference and it's made a
difference to keeping people in work
primarily which is what we're trying to
do
and but yes you're right that can't go
on you know now is not the time
to make those decisions because we're
dealing with so much uncertainty with
the economy the obr yesterday
presented three different scenarios but
once we get through this and we have
greater certainty about the outlook we
can't obviously have a situation
uh where we're borrowing this march and
debt is going up forever
um well i i can't tell you exactly when
but what i can tell you is we do need to
re restore the public finances
to a strong position surprises are
inevitable i can't i can't comment on
fiscal policy outside of budgets okay
and i i apologize for that but what
what you can but it's not going to come
from a money tree is it
well well what i'd say is i don't want
to get drawn on speculation about taxes
speculating money's going to come from
somewhere
but when we get to an appropriate point
where we have certainty of the economy
we'll look at how best to make sure that
we have strong public finances
and and the reason for that is simple
i've been able to respond in a
comprehensive and generous way during
this crisis
in part because of the decisions of my
predecessors which meant that we came
into this with a strong
set of public finances you know i want
to make sure whenever the next difficult
thing comes along
that the chancellor can do the same
response that i've done and that will
require us to make sure we get back to
that strong position maybe when your
prime minister who knows
um as far as tears are concerned i know
that you're not going if i ask you what
tears people are going to be and you're
not going to tell me you're going to say
um that the health secretary will tell
me that at half past 11 of course we'll
cover that on sky news
but i suppose what what i would like to
ask you is
when we come out of lockdown will we
will it feel
any different yeah for a lot of people
yeah no i think that is a
a completely fair question and you're
right the health sector will make a
statement later
the um prime minister will also do a
press conference later today and we have
a cabinet meeting which i can get back
to after all of this where we're going
to
finalize all the decisions and so thank
you for bearing with me on that
and you're right look it's this is all
enormously frustrating uh no one enjoys
this but i think people will see
a difference i think in all cases you
already know shops will be open
everywhere personal care there's
relaxations on what can happen
outdoors communal worship
so all of those things will change
obviously changes to the curfew
so whichever tier you're in i think
people will see a tangible change
that said if things are obviously not
normal i can't pretend that next week
things are going to feel like they were
before spring um
you know we are going to have to live
with these restrictions as we get
through a difficult winter
but because of the the hard work and the
sacrifices especially of the last four
weeks we're in a much better place
and testing has uh hugely ramped up and
that
gives us i think every confidence that
we can get through the winter in good
shape why didn't you mention
brexit yesterday well the negotiations
are ongoing
and i think the teams are hard at work
they're working intensively
and you know i remain hopeful that with
a constructive attitude
i'm an optimistic person but you know
there's there's a lot of work
going on and i think with a constructive
attitude and goodwill on all sides
you know we can get there and it's clear
what the shape of a deal looks like
and as i said it you know requires a
constructive attitude but i think on our
part we've always been
very consistent and transparent about
what we need
the things that are important to us why
ultimately we voted for brexit and what
needs to be
delivered and you know i'm hopeful that
the eu will see that the vast majority
of what we're asking for are things that
they've already agreed with other
countries
and we've done that deliberately and
therefore as i said i know the teams are
hard at work and
let's see okay um you've got the double
whammy of brexit and covert to deal with
um
next year flipping
it's going to be a hard year for you
isn't it well i hope it can't be any
harder than uh
well it can't because you're still
dealing with what from what the
ramifications of this year and then
you've got to deal with the
ramifications of brexit yeah well you i
mean you talk about ramifications look
obviously
in the short term especially it would be
preferable to have a deal but
we've put an enormous amount of effort
and resource
into preparing the country especially
businesses
for the change in our trading
relationship which is happening you know
regardless of the exact shape
uh of the trading arrangements that we
that we can negotiate
so that's hundreds of millions invested
in improving our port infrastructure
more border force officials a trader
support service for traders in northern
ireland
we've we've helped support the ramp up
of something called customs
intermediaries which are the businesses
that help process customs forms for
businesses
so all of that taken together and on our
end we're only phasing in our customs
requirements slowly over the course of
next year
you know that's an enormous amount of
support for business to help them with
the transition
and cost and yes yes of course but those
investments are ones that we have to
make in all cases regardless of the
exact shape of the trading relationship
but i think that businesses have done a
great job
and and obviously you know not current
of ours notwithstanding
we're in a far better place than we were
last year you're a football fan i think
southampton
that is right um how will you remember
maradona
well you know actually sally i was very
young when the world cup happened i was
only six years old so i can't remember
watching it
live when um when all these things
happened but i've seen it a million
a million times since an enormous talent
uh my obviously
my favorite football player would be
matt lescizzier
so uh another mercurial i mean a lot of
people compare them often
well as they rightly should i think
actually but um but i think
i think gary linda said that it's it's
in a rare that
you know you're playing a game and you
want to stop and applaud someone who's
just scored a goal against you
and you know for for going to feel like
that just shows you
what an amazing moment that was when he
scored against us in 86 but you know his
enormous talent and obviously
um a complicated life but let's remember
him for his extraordinary football
skills and enjoy watching all his goals
and just before i let you go uh just
before we were
live on air you did say that the kids
could have a dog
do you want to just repeat that because
they're probably watching you this
morning they're not
no you didn't say that you were gonna go
and then they could have a dog i do try
and avoid it and every week or so it
does come back
what happened is my wife has switched
sides in this debate over the course of
the first lockdown
and i think that has uh that has done
for me so um but probably next year that
will happen
yes i'm trying to you know trying to
push it off but okay kids you're having
a dog
dad says definitely not they should not
be watching it's good to see you thank
you thank you very much
thank you